joining us now someone who sadly has
some experience with the issue the
professional footballer lee nickel lee
lovely to see you this morning and i
wish we were talking about another topic
but because you know where i'm going to
start i wonder if you could just remind
us
exactly what happened to you back in
2019 some personal videos of you has
made their way online
yeah thank you for having me back in
2019 i became the victim of revenge porn
a little bit different to the
blackmailing scams that is going on at
the minute but it's totally relatable to
the emotions behind it so the
humiliation the victim blaming the guilt
the shame
and so i can relate to that part of it
and it is it it's increasing severely
and really really quickly but
back in 2019 when i did go through what
i went through this was a crime that i
knew absolutely nothing about and you
blame yourself so as the individuals
that we blame us and and those people
that are getting caught out sending
images online everyone will blame
themselves but i think there's only one
group of people to blame here and that
is the criminals behind it
yeah i mean
you yourself suffered physically
physically and mentally as i understand
it i mean how how was that period for
you young women you know working in
professional football you know you
should give up the world like world and
a football at your feet and then
something like this happens
yeah the impact was huge it was life
changing for me if it took me away from
from the game for a year i wasn't strong
enough to continue
to fight for those three points to fight
for a position in the team to put up
with potential comments on the pitch and
it was it was the last thing i was
worried about and
me at six years old my first love in
life was football and to have that taken
away from me because an off-pitch matter
was
was something that i've not quite got
over myself yet but the damage mentally
was absolutely huge and some people
don't recover from it and i guess that's
that's why i now do what i do when i
speak up because some people don't ever
recover and some people never find that
strength to be able to walk out the door
feeling guilt-free or shame-free or stop
blaming themselves
and it's good that you're out there and
talking about your experiences lee i
think and correct me if i'm wrong here i
think i remember an interview you gave
with sky sports at around about the time
that this had come out that they should
come oh in fact after this had all come
out and you talked about the fact that
in the dressing room at crystal palace
above you know the place where you keep
your kit there was a picture and
sometimes people put pictures of their
families there you had a picture of a
tree a tree in your garden the tree
where you
once planned to end your life
yeah
every morning and through that period of
my life i would wake up and i'd see
a tree standing alone and it was the
first thing that i've seen every morning
last thing i've seen every night and i
believe that that tree was a sign that
that was where i had to take my my own
life and i planned at my head and i was
battling those thoughts continuously but
as weeks went on i had to turn my
perspective into looking at that tree
differently and that was really
difficult and
i woke up one morning i just thought
look at that tree it survived all the
rain up all night and now it's sunny and
it's still standing and sometimes it
loses these branches it loses leaves but
it's still standing and it grows again
and and that that for me that change of
perspective now that wasn't just a light
bulb moment that wasn't like a i looked
at it and it changed my life but me
changing my mentality towards the tree
and towards everything else going on in
my life that was really what saved my
life because i just kept looking at that
tree thinking this is it and this is
where it's going to happen
mainly as you say that there are there
are differences um between you know the
the the revenge pawn uh and indeed this
extortion that's going on at the moment
seems to be an awful lot more of kind of
organized criminal involvement in the
latter but but another difference we
tend to perceive those who are suffering
from from revenge porn as being women
the statistics on this showing that in
terms of sex torsion actually eight
you're a significant majority of those
who are complaining of it who have been
a victim of it are men i mean this is
something that can happen to all of us
yeah it can happen to young boys young
girls
men and women um
but what we're seeing at the minute is a
criminal operation of
that is operating outside the uk at the
minute that is seen to be targeting men
at the minute
and
is our jobs and my firm and my my
company's job to make sure that we are
there to pick up the pieces when it goes
wrong and we are there to raise
awareness so that people aren't falling
for these scams because the they're
doing a very good job at it
give us give us the advice then of
course i mean you you've said crystal
palace we're there for you and your
corner
not everyone has a has a football team
uh willing to willing to back them up
when when occasions like this come along
so to tell us what would your advice be
to someone who finds themselves in a
situation similar to yours or indeed at
one of those sex torsion scans
i think we all everyone around the
individual and including themselves you
need to try and stay as calm as possible
not to panic i think the friends and
family and professionals around them
need to
not not judge place no judgment on them
and just be there to offer the emotional
support the arm around them when they
need it and just be there for them and i
think that's that's all we can do at the
minute you need to go and get
professional support when this does
happen you need to make sure
reaching out to revenge porn helpline
and media lawyers that can help getting
that get this took out um off the
internet but do not fall for it do not
send these people any money and those
around them just keep them calm it's
going to be okay don't add to the chaos
don't don't add fuel to the fire don't
tell them things that are being said
online or just stay calm because
everything else is chaos
some very good advice there lee and look
we got through an entire interview and i
didn't even ask you what you thought
about the final in the seville this week
as well um lee nickel lovely to see you
and thanks so much for taking the time
really appreciate it
bye guys